Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright!
No taunting your future hosts!
Dr. Bright is a force of chaos that annot
be bound to only one mortal form.
We all know this.
His consciousness is contained in that pretty
little amulet around his neck.
Every so often, like a hermit crab changing
its shell, Dr. Bright moves on from his human
host to take up residence in a new flesh shell.
Ugh.
Anyway, Dr. Bright is not allowed to taunt
or harass his future hosts in any way, including
telling them "You are about to become very
Bright," saying "Possession is nine-tenths
of the law," or referring to D-Class personnel
as "extra lives."
You'll never have a career in stand-up, Doctor.